[Music]
if you go to summer school you became a
better community cuz what it was the
summer school was all three towns class
clowns drug addicts rebels all like they
distilled all the people that gave his
[ __ ] did homework right and respected
teachers and I remember going to
thinking I was funny it was like going
from high school to the college level
going like well then the whole new level
of football these guys hit harder what I
loved about him and why was so
fascinated by is they didn't think
consequence they just thought hey I'm
doing this and then they redo it and
then they just dealt with it this guy's
mowing the lawn and one of these class
clowns guys he just saw him coming by
and just happened to have a coke in his
hand and without saying do you dare be
or anything it's just impulsive he just
poured it on him and I don't think I
have a laugh so [ __ ] hard a month I
couldn't believe he did it so then we
sit down and classes start again I can't
even hold it like I'm trying to duck
behind the kid in front of me just
thinking of this guy in the Sun with his
coke and then all of a sudden there's a
knock on the door right and this [ __ ]
guy comes in all this stuff like the
brown stains of the coke on his wife
cedar oh my god I just want to see
something and the teacher doesn't know
it's any and he walked out and he looked
out the window and he saw the wet spot
so yeah it's dead so somebody had
portico con me because I am thought I am
crying laughing like he's like okay who
did it and like a normal class people
would all clam him get nervous the kid
who did is like yeah I did I want credit
for this kid I did it